I met Trump at the ufcs last week in
Miami right yeah how was that it was
interesting man I mean you're like you
know I mean I love being at UFC right so
it's like for me it is literally it's
like being like you ever been um
baptized or whatever yeah
don't recall it but yeah I mean I I feel
like though I've never been to UFC but
just the the vibe of it how they just
have everybody there it just seems like
one big I guess for you obviously just
an interesting VIP party it's a who's
it's almost like uh like the Oscars for
cool guys if that makes sense it feels
like it's the who's who of actually who
has some [__] nuts you know that's
what it feels like a little bit and I'm
not even saying me but it feels like you
know that's the energy that Dana has you
know yes um
you know I got to talk to him for like
maybe 12 minutes just even talk about
like some work stuff and like uh uh you
know and he's had a lot of great success
and what he was sharing and stuff like
that and so that was really cool how to
work with the advertisers some business
stuff but then like
Kid Rock is there he rolls in with Trump
you know we're in like Dana White's
dress green room right and I've been
trying to do some like
um maybe some Social Media stuff with
UFC so it was my first time like doing
some of that but I get to be backstage
by the fighters you know it's like
you're getting baptized but right when
you come up two dudes are beating the
[__] out of each other right yeah so
it's like that bro and uh yeah there's
just so much going on you turn this way
somebody said because they've you know
their stuff they're going through defeat
and Agony this way somebody's a hero
this way they're you know they somebody
just Flatline this way there's like some
uh of a ring model trying on a new top
this way there's uh Joe burrow in uh the
boastable yeah Jefferson was there I
think yeah I saw a punch people there
this way there's
um just some lady that's there that has
the biggest tits ever right and it's
like she has some jack dude he's
literally carrying one of her tits
probably tatted up oh he was so tired of
course he was and she can't even carry
both tits so she's balanced and he's
literally carrying the other
so it just there's so much going on but
then Trump rolled in and um
it was just interesting you know you got
I never met a president before and I'd
never met Donald Trump before now don't
take us the wrong way but do you did he
know who you were no he didn't his son
know uh knows me Donald Jr and um I
don't know if his other son Eric knew or
not but it was just interesting you know
yeah Mike him and Mike Tyson rolled it
at the same time I'm assuming him he's
going to this event knowing everybody is
going to just be there and he's gonna
have to say kind of make it seem like he
knows you no matter who he's talking to
because he where he is everybody is I
guess of notoriety now as a as a person
that gets to go to those things do you
would you say you're more excited going
into the night to see the fights or to
just the spectacle of it oh I think the
fights uh for sure yeah I've never been
to one where you're that close up that
close up that seems like kind of a
once you go there you can't sit can't
sit up high yeah I mean I think I I
would just to see the fights but it
definitely I felt real fortunate you
know uh to go and yeah you're just
seeing these guys and like when they're
putting it on the line you know like I
think in a lot of ways comedians
um uh a strippers
um
Fighters yes sir you know anybody that
does something that puts themselves out
there they're you're all trying to gain
like to be seen in some way you know
some you're all using something you have
to attract
uh
to get acceptance kind of in a way 100 I
mean that's I mean I've never done setup
that's one thing I always tell myself
about if I ever go to a comedy club or
my friends send a clip of somebody doing
stand up I will never say anything bad
if bad about anybody at the center if
you have the balls to get up there all
power to you yeah I think
all power to you yeah that's how I am
about Fighters I think because it's just
so like I always had a tough time
defending myself when I was a kid and so
you know I didn't feel like I had
protection and [__] so you get to see
these guys who are doing it and then and
find out the different reasons that
they're doing it and it's all to me it's
real fascinating you're gonna do a lot
of fights growing up no
I got into maybe six fights oh you know
that's hot
and uh we had a lot of brothers in the
area too serving now and then a brother
will flare up out of nowhere you know
and you'll be in a fight but um
but yeah
but it was it was it was interesting and
Trump's just like you're good how are
you doing you're doing good in president
mode yeah you're great you're doing
great your parents are doing good yeah
it was just he's so like yeah he said
you know I was like my dad's been dead
for like 42 years and he's like but
before that he was doing great
like you know what he was he was doing
great before that but actually I kind of
like I was like you know what I
appreciate that that was worth the price
of admission that was better than any
fight you're gonna see
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one